Alec Baldwin has been charged again with
involuntary manslaughter for his fatal
shooting on the set of rust if convicted
this could lead to Serious consequences
for the actor someone is responsible for
what happened and I can't say who that
is but I know it's not me in 2021
Baldwin was filming the Western rust
when he used a prop gun filled with live
ammunition the actor was rehearsing a
scene that involved the actor's
character Outlaw Harland rust firing a
gun towards the camera in preparing for
the scene the gun fired and killed the
film cinematographer Helena Hutchin
Hutchin was a rising talent in the world
of cinematography having lent her
talents to the 2020 superhero flick Arch
Enemy following Hutch's death filming on
the production was paused and the actor
was charged with two counts of
involuntary manslaughter in April 2023
the charges were dropped once cleared of
charges production on the picture
continued but while the film may be
completed Baldwin isn't done dealing
with the aftermath of what happened on
the set of rust this is a case that is a
zombie case it has died it has been
reanimated on Friday a grand jury in New
Mexico once again indicted the 30 Rock
actor on a charge of involuntary
manslaughter the New Mexico grand jury
presented the indictment after evidence
from special prosecutors Ki morresy and
Jason Lewis was brought forward
Baldwin's lawyers Luke Nikas and Alex
spau issued a statement on Friday
obtained by the New York Times saying we
look forward to our day in court the
decision to indict Baldwin once again
again comes after The Local District
Attorney's prosecution failed to find
footing this eventually led to the
initial dismissal of charges in the wake
of the shooting several lawsuits
manifested including one from the
cinematographers family the initial
prosecution team argued that Baldwin
willfully disregarded the safety of
those on set despite alleging that he
did not know that the gun was filled
with live ammunition a grand jury of 12
came together on Thursday January 18th
to hear the matters of the case for the
charge to move forward eight jurors had
to have agreed that there was probable
cause to indict the actor it's worth
noting that the indictment charged the
rust actor and producer with two
different involuntary counts of
manslaughter he can however be only
convicted of one official court
documents reveal that one is far more
severe than the other with one being a
felony the second alternative count
reads that Baldwin quote did cause the
death of Helena Hutchins by an act
committed with the total disregard or
indifference for the safety of others
meanwhile Baldwin has consistently and
continually maintained that Hutch's
death is not his fault discussing how he
was told that the gun did not have any
live ammunition the actor also claimed
that he did not fire the weapon which
led to the death of the cinematographer
a forensic report commissioned by the
prosecution however suggests differently
arguing that Baldwin did pull the
trigger if convicted by the New Mexico
Court Baldwin could face up to 18 months
in prison but Baldwin wasn't the only
creative member of rust to face scrutiny
Hannah Gutierrez Reed the film's armorer
who was responsible for the film's
weapons was is also charged with
involuntary manslaughter after pleading
not guilty her trial will begin in
February later this year Baldwin has
always known that charges could once
again be brought up against him this was
always a possibility once the initial
charges were dismissed while it remains
to be seen what verdict the actor
receives the legacy of rust has already
been cemented production on the picture
has wrapped up though it remains to be
seen when or if the film will be
released Bianca Klein replaced Hutchin
as the film cinematographer following
the death of Helena Hutchins the larger
film and television industry has made
significant efforts to reduce the
possibility of another rust-like
incident the boys showrunner Eric kryy
was one of several industry Giants to
come out and disavow the future use of
Blanks on set John Wick franchise
Steward and stuntman Chad stahelski has
also discussed the incident on the set
of rust calling out Hollywood creatives
for using real guns on set saying that
the use of CG and electronic prop guns
should be the norm going
forward
m